morning everybody it is seven o'clock
very welcome to join us on the breakfast
show here on sky news thursday morning a
fresh warning from vladimir putin that
russia will respond if nato sets up
military infrastructure in finland and
sweden after the nordic countries were
formally invited to join the uk
meanwhile says it will help ensure putin
fails in ukraine as the prime minister
pledged an extra thousand soldiers to
help bolster nato's forces and another
billion pounds in support to kiev still
the pm won't commit to extra funding for
britain's military despite russia's
threat lots to discuss for the foreign
secretary liz trusts who will join us
very shortly from madrid and labour's
shadow defense secretary is also on this
morning's programme it's thursday the
30th of june
as russia issues a fresh threat to nato
boris johnson pledges more help for
ukraine to help ensure putin's failure
the promise of more support from the
nato summit here too with britain
promising an additional billion pounds
in aid to ukraine and another thousand
troops committed to the defense of
estonia
we'll report from salisbury where the uk
is already training ukrainian soldiers
to help improve their battle readiness
the cost of the royals more than a
hundred million pounds spent by the
monarchy last year while buckingham
palace refuses to release details of the
megan bullying report
charity controversy the captain tom
foundation is investigated over
management concerns
bataclan massacre the only surviving
member of a group of islamic state
members who carried out terror attacks
in paris is sentenced to life in jail
30 years behind bars for the disgraced r
b singer r kelly for using his fame to
sexually abuse young fans
homegrown hopes dampened at wimbledon as
andy murray and ebba redacano crash out
in the second round
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning
[Music]
australia's worst mass shooting we'll
speak to the director of a new film
about the port arthur massacre and ask
what it can teach the world about gun
control
and testing the limits meeting the
former british soldier bidding to become
the world's first double above knee
amputee to climb everest
[Music]
morning everyone boris johnson says
vladimir putin threatens peace and
security across europe the prime
minister has promised more military
support to the alliance and to ukraine
that's as vladimir putin says russia
will respond in kind if nato sets up
infrastructure in sweden and finland
the warning comes after the nordic
countries signed an agreement for them
to join the alliance
we do not have such problems with sweden
and finland that we have with ukraine
unfortunately
we have no territorial issues or
disputes we have nothing to worry about
in terms of membership of sweden and
finland in nato
they want it after all they only must
clearly understand that there were no
threats to them before
now if military contingents and
infrastructure are deployed there we
will have to respond in a mirror manner
well standing by dominic in madrid as he
has been over the last couple of
mornings um hello to dominic hearing
from the foreign secretary in just a
second how anxious do you think nato
countries are about the latest comments
from putin
i think they will be concerned but they
will probably say that they are fairly
predictable i mean vladimir putin was
going to respond way one way or another
to sweden and finland joining the nato
alliance it has to be said uh it's kind
of his faults he said he's fought this
war because he wants to stop nato
expanding but it's been so alarming for
sweden and finland they've got over
their long tradition of neutrality and
have rushed to join the alliance and
turkey has got over its objections to
that happening so sweden and finland
joining the alliance and what putin has
said is that
if nato puts military infrastructure
into those nordic countries then he will
respond in kind on his side of the
border what that means isn't entirely
clear is he talking about barracks is he
talking about brigade headquarters he's
talking about buildings or equipment or
is he referring to troops if nato troops
go in there is he saying he's going to
match that on the other side so i think
it's it's rhetoric and we've heard a lot
of that from putin over the last few
months it will cause concern but i think
nato leaders will take it in their
stride okay and i think what we're going
to hear from leaders today apart from
discussing terrorism is probably going
to be more of what we're hearing from
boris johnson the prime minister he is
going to be talking about the kind of
aid that can be given to ukraine
yesterday we heard very much about how
nato is going to defend itself against
the threat from russia in the years
ahead but i think we'll hear more about
how it can help ukraine fight back
against russia so that billion pounds in
aid you're talking about from britain is
going to take uh britain's contribution
to the ukrainian war
war effort to 2.3
billion pounds so that's almost doubling
it it's going to be helping the
ukrainians with drones with air defense
systems with electronic warfare
equipment and kits for ukrainian
soldiers we're told and what the uk is
saying it's going to help the ukrainians
switch pivots from defending themselves
against russia's aggression and more
against offense against launching a
counteract counter-attack against the
russians to push the russians out and as
we've been hearing from military
analysts for a while to do that the
ukrainians need to completely
restructure their military they need a
lot more equipment but they need to
change the way they operate
strategically and to that end or helping
that the british have been helping train
the ukrainians on the salisbury plain
and in the uk so i think it is a pretty
fundamental shift we're going to see
here
starting here trying to help the
ukrainians to now win back the territory
they've been losing to russia
okay dominic thank you
let's bring in the foreign secretary
should we lose trust also in madrid for
us this morning hello to ms trust thanks
for joining us will nato be setting up
military infrastructure in finland and
sweden
well what we announced yesterday is that
we are upping our presence across the
eastern flank making sure that all of
our allies are secure and this is vital
because we face a much more uncertain
and insecure europe and that is why
we've also seen finland and sweden join
for years and years they remain neutral
but they can now see the very real
threat from russia so what's ended up is
that putin who wanted less nato has now
got more nato but it will be a matter
for
finland and sweden to discuss with nato
exactly how that will work exactly what
is set up in finland and sweden but i'm
absolutely delighted that they are now
on the path to becoming nato members and
they will really help strengthen our
alliance yeah okay so it's not just
being members we are going to see
military infrastructure in place in
finland and sweden as well as nato is
concerned we've heard what president
putin has said he says that if that was
to be the case russia would respond in
kind
what would nato do about that
we've heard this rhetoric from putin
about all kinds of plans in the past so
he said that it was a red line for him
uh that finland and sweden would join
nato he said it was a red line if uh
western nations supplied weapons to
ukraine this is rhetoric we have to
ignore the rhetoric and instead do all
we can to continue to support ukraine
with the weapons they need to win this
appalling war because if we don't it
means that there'll be much greater
threat for european security in the
future today we've announced an extra
billion pounds of military aid to
ukraine to help them push russia out of
their territory and we have to focus on
keeping going
keeping the support going to ukraine
keeping the sanctions on russia and
really ignoring uh the rhetoric from
vladimir putin what matters is what
happens on the ground but the rhetoric
is now ratcheting up to cold war levels
during the cold war um our spending in
the uk was five percent of gdp how much
more would you like to see an increase
of the spending as a percentage of gdp
here in the uk
well our spending is currently 2.3
percent of gdp we put an extra 24
billion pounds of spending in yesterday
or today we announced the extra billion
to support ukraine what we now need to
see is our allies and partners step up
because the figure you quoted k is a
figure for nato overall some partners
are still not spending the two percent i
see the two percent as a flaw it's a
minimum and we need to make sure that
we're all contributing and making sure
that the
defense and deterrence is much more
effective uh than what we have seen for
the past 20 years which i fear has
enabled uh putin to
carry out this appalling war
okay so ben wallace um the defense
secretary saying he's looking for more
come the middle of the decade and then
the next spending review would you agree
with him
i agree that we need to make sure that
all of the western alliance is spending
more on defense and putting more into
particularly to supporting our eastern
allies i'm not going to get into details
of the negotiations of the spending
review
i think it is imperative that we do
make sure that our defense budget is fit
for purpose and also able to deal with
the modern challenges like cyber warfare
uh the issues that we face in space as
well
okay is it fit for purpose
we are
so we we're following through on the
integrated review uh that we put
together last year
we are focusing on what uh what we need
to supply across the board uh we have
been at the forefront of support to
ukraine uh we are the
first european country to send weapons
to ukraine but of course we continue to
need to support them in the future to
make sure that they win
and that they prevail over russia yeah
but going into the last election and the
government felt that the manifesto
pledge should be that defense spending
uh continues at 0.5 percent above
inflation that's not going to happen is
it
well i don't think anybody anticipated a
global pandemic and i don't think
anybody anticipated that we would be
facing a huge economic
uh
shock
in the shape of
huge inflation right across the world so
we are in extraordinary times but given
we're in those extraordinary times we
continue to focus on our defense that's
where we're able to provide this extra
billion pounds worth of funding to
ukraine and it's why we put 24 billion
pound extra into the defense budget but
you won't go as far as the defense
secretary saying that he's going to be
looking to the chancellor and the prime
minister at the next spending review for
a significant increase
well as i've said we we're all
negotiating our budgets for the next
spending review i've been very clear
that the entire free world the western
alliance does need to focus more on
deterrence we need to focus more on
defence and what we know is prevention
is better than cure
the lesson that putin learned from under
spending on defence was that he could
invade a sovereign nation and we simply
can't that we can't let our guard down
again we can't allow that to happen
again
prime minister says that the army is the
right size and the leader the head of
the army says it isn't what would you
say
i i would say that we need a full range
of
capabilities to deal with the threats
that we face now whether those are cyber
threats whether those are land-based
threats naval threats and we have the
balance right but of course we need to
continue to evolve because we're seeing
you know we never expected in our
lifetimes to see this kind of war
on you know in in europe and do you know
we have to cut off ten thousand troops
is my question
i i support our plans on defense but but
what i'm saying is we need to continue
to evolve them
as
we face new and different threats and i
don't think any of us
expected to see
this type of war on european land in our
lifetimes okay
i'm not sure you answered my question
but there we are the defense secretary
has called vladimir putin a lunatic with
small man's syndrome the pm says he's
stupid and crazy how would you describe
him
well what i would say is that he has
he has ordered the most appalling crimes
to be committed uh in ukraine uh we've
seen
uh this systematic rape of women uh
we've seen the attacking of civilians
including at shopping center last week
and what we need to make sure is not
only
are the ukrainians successful in pushing
russia out of ukraine but also that
people are held to account
for these appalling crimes that have
been committed how would you describe
him
well i would describe him as a
appalling dictator perpetrating
a
a war that was neither legal nor
justified in any possible way
of sound mind
i've not met vladimir putin i do not
know
the motivations for
carrying out this appalling war all i
know
is that we have to make it our absolute
priority
to stop this war to push vladimir putin
and the russian troops out of
ukraine otherwise we will live in a much
less safe europe
talk to me about the commons foreign
affairs select committee um
they say that uh your department was too
slow to impose sanctions on russia and
clamp down on corrupt russian money
being laundered in the uk in other words
dirty money was being laundered and your
department should have done more about
it and they were too slow to act how
would you respond well we have
sanctioned as a country
more individuals and entities in russia
than any other government in the world
we passed emergency legislation as soon
as uh this appalling war was perpetrated
as soon as russia invaded ukraine and
we've been able to
hit
russia hard with sanctions uh most
recently we uh sanctioned russian gold
and we're working with our allies across
the world to do that and the uk has led
on this it was back last year in
liverpool at the g7 that we agreed with
our allies that there would be severe
sanctions
if putin invaded ukraine we've followed
through on that and we've delivered the
biggest package of sanctions of any
country yeah but the report goes on to
say it was shameful that it had taken a
war the ukraine war for ministers to
introduce the economic crime act
we acted as soon as we could to deal
with the appalling consequences of the
war in ukraine and our priority is
cutting off the funding that putin is
using to perpetrate this war and that is
why it's very important that we
end the purchase of oil we end the
purchase of gas from russia we're
encouraging our european allies to do
that because ultimately that is what
will cut off funding for the war machine
and what i'm focused on as foreign
secretary is making sure that we have
the effective means of stopping this war
so you don't accept the criticism from
the committee
i don't we acted very quickly and we
have done more than any other country in
terms of the number of individuals and
entities we've sanctioned okay harriet
harmon
is going to be or is indeed chair of the
privileged missy which will be looking
into partygate and whether the prime
minister lied to parliament or not ben
wallace defense secretary yesterday told
me that he didn't see a problem with
that what do you think
i don't see a problem with that either
but the committee clearly has to take
its course and make its judgment
as i've said before i'm 100 supportive
of the prime minister and what people
want us to be doing in britain is
getting on with the priorities
working to make sure this appalling war
in ukraine is ended
getting the economy going after the huge
shock of covert and that is what we are
focused on type that's what we're
focused on as government ministers so
you don't share the anxiety shared by
some apparently conservative mps well
conservative mps apparently sharing the
anxiety that
that it's going to be a kangaroo court
and it's not fit for purpose
no we have these processes in parliament
it's the process has kicked off we now
need to wait for the result
um do you think the prime minister
should um just bite the bullet and go
for a snap election he won't rule it out
what do you think he should do
as i've said we are focused on
delivering for the british people we're
facing the worst war in europe for
decades we've got the
aftershock of the pandemic which is
having huge effects around the world on
inflation on people's incomes on
economic growth we are spending our time
focused on dealing with those challenges
not speculating about elections so it
shouldn't be until 2024.
others said we're not thinking about
that we're thinking about getting on
with the job you're not running it out
then there are you foreign secretary
well i'm i'm i'm focused on getting on
with the job there is a lot to be done
uh making sure that the ukrainians have
all they need to deal with this
appalling uh invasion by russia making
sure that we help our allies
particularly our allies on the eastern
front and the eastern flank who face
who face threat from russia making sure
that we deal with the longer-term threat
of china as well you know that is what
i'm spending my time on okay we must let
you go madam foreign secretary thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you
what are the papers saying this morning
well let's start with the times it's
leading with a pledge from the uk the
u.s and germany to send more troops to
nato's eastern flank just hearing about
that from the foreign secretary after
the alliance officially recognized
russia as its most significant threat
the metro says a new iron curtain is
emerging in europe with the us alone
planning to station a hundred thousand
troops near russia's border
despite the growing threat from russia
the uk military will get no extra cash
for its military for at least three
years just hearing about that as well
weren't we that's the eyes front page
headline guardian focusing on research
that has found that privatization of the
nhs has aligned with a decline in
quality and an increase in the rate of
deaths from treatable causes
and this that i put to the foreign
secretary the daily telegraph reporting
that downing street sources say that the
inquiry looking into whether the prime
minister misled parliament over
partygate risks becoming a kangaroo
court she completely disagrees with that
allegation
still to come on the programme
as western leaders continue to meet for
the final day of the nato summit in
madrid i'll be speaking to the uk's
former permanent representative to the
alliance that's adam thompson
eight o'clock i'll be speaking to
labour's shadow defense secretary john
healey what do they think about the pm's
pledge of further military support for
nato and ukraine
and discussing the report into the
moniker's expenditure with the royal
author norman baker
[Music]
to that end buckingham palace facing
questions about why it won't reveal more
about the findings of an investigation
into bullying allegations made against
the duchess of sussex it comes as the
royal family's annual finances show the
monarchy cost taxpayers more than a
hundred million pounds for the first
time here's rihanna
the complaints were serious allegations
megan had bullied staff claims that she
has always denied but after the palace
privately hired a law firm to look not
into what was said or done but how it
was handled they now won't tell us what
the findings are a senior palace source
said because of the confidentiality of
the discussions we have not communicated
the detailed recommendations the
recommendations have been incorporated
within policies and procedures wherever
appropriate and policies and procedures
have changed so all members of staff all
members of the royal family will be
aware
experts believe they could have gone
further if they wanted to if the palace
want to
keep things on an even keel between
the family which is what i think they
probably do want to do
and um keep their public relations
positive i think they they should
probably say something along the lines
of some protocols were not followed and
we've intervened to to make sure these
are more robust and training has been
given that kind of thing a little bit
more i suppose taking responsibility
former staff i've spoken to say only a
very limited number of people were
involved in the investigation others
clearly just want to move on but it's
all again come up as the palace let us
look at their annual finances which show
the monarchy cost the taxpayer
102.4 million pounds in the past
financial year
prince charles is two days in barbados
to see it becoming a republic costing a
hundred and thirty eight thousand pounds
and the cambridge's caribbean week-long
tour more than
226 000
they are now using sustainable fuel on
the royal flight where they can to boost
their environmental credentials
is it appropriate to accept
millions of tax for your charity sir
it has been a week where the issue of
transparency has already come up after
reports prince charles was given bags of
cash for his charity by a former qatari
prime minister not illegal and a senior
aide has said it wouldn't happen now
but certainly raising questions about
judgment and the optics of what they
seem to do
which is why a lack of openness
especially around matters involving
family continues to clash with their
preferred image of a forward thinking
institution
rhiannon mills sky news
now an investigation has been launched
into the captain tom foundation after
the charity commission identified
concerns about its management and
independence from the late veterans
family sabbah is with us what's the
problem morning morning kay well you
know this is something that really is so
far etched into the public's
consciousness we think of captain sir
tom moore we think of him walking around
his garden 100 laps before his 100th
birthday as we can see uh in the screen
there raising 38 million pounds now what
the issue is is that the charity
commission which is basically a charity
watchdog have launched an inquiry
looking into the management of the
foundation and the degree of the
family's involvement so for example his
the late veteran's daughter hannah
she has something like uh 800 000 pounds
that her company that she uh owns uh
made from trademarking her late father's
name and in addition to that there were
some issues relating to her salary for
when she was temporarily chief executive
of
the foundation so initially that she
wanted something like 60 grand for three
days a week which was rejected
then that became a hundred thousand
pounds for full-time a full-time basis
which the regulators then rejected and
then eventually they did agree uh on a
full amount now the family or the
foundation i should say have uh welcomed
this news and we uh have got a
statement from them so they're basically
saying that they are satisfied um with
the fact that the charity commission um
they are rather welcome that the charity
commission has reported that it is
satisfied about questions that have been
raised about the foundation's report
which was published back in february
earlier this year
at the fact that it has concluded that
payments were reasonable and that
conflicts of interest were identified
and managed they've also said that the
question of uh
image and uh intellectual property
rights remained with the family's
private family trust
so to them this really is not an issue
but to the uh charity commission they're
very much seeing this as a matter of
public interest uh and about protecting
the public's trust in donating to good
causes so what happens now
well we're just gonna have to wait and
see uh what the charity commission find
so we'll we'll just have to hope for the
best really nice question okay for now
thanks so much
also making news for you today the only
surviving member of the islamic state
group which carried out the attack on
the bataclan concert hall in paris has
been sentenced to life with no parole
salah abdul sam is one of 20 people
convicted on charges relating to the
attack in 2015
which killed 130 people and injured
hundreds more a survivor said the court
had done its job
the worst thing and i told that to my
brother is that now they are in our
heads so
and it's exactly that seven years after
they're still there and uh
yeah the court did they did their job
perfect and now it's our own job to
continue to recover
more than 40 flights have been cancelled
at heathrow today around 1200 flights
were due to leave it comes just weeks
after the airport asked airlines to
cancel 10 of flights amid baggage
handling problems staff shortages at
many airports and airlines have caused
disruption for travellers over the last
few weeks
two men have been charged with human
trafficking offences after dozens of
migrants were found dead in the back of
a truck in texas the suspected driver of
the truck and an alleged conspiracy face
a maximum sentence of life in prison or
the possibility of the death penalty
the british medical association says
americans who can't access abortions
should be offered free services in the
uk british doctors also want buffer
zones to be placed around abortion
clinics to prevent protesters from
harassing patients the move comes after
the u.s supreme court's decision to end
the legal right of american women to
have abortions
gordon brown has told sky news that the
uk is at war with the us the former
prime minister told sky's beth rigby
that britain and america will continue
to be in the trade war unless the issues
over the northern ireland protocol are
resolved
if we cannot repair our relations with
europe and america and we're at war if
you like with both of them for different
reasons but all related war with america
what with america over ireland because
america will not sign a trade treaty
with britain as long as we cannot sort
out the issues relating to ireland
president biden i asked him about this
explicitly
last year last september and he did say
that he thought the two things were
separate that there was a trade deal and
then there was the good friday but he
may think that but the american congress
will not think that there's no chance of
a trade deal between britain and america
unless we can sort out the problems that
arise in ireland
and more on that interview with beth at
nine o'clock this evening
the british billionaire richard branson
has become the latest famous face to
meet president zielenski in kiev
officials say they discussed cooperation
on ukraine's post-war reconstruction and
maintaining global attention on the
conflict mr branson said sir richard i
should say said the purpose of his visit
was to learn what business can do to
effectively support ukraine
the disgraced r b singer
r kelly has been sentenced to 30 years
in prison for using his celebrity status
to sexually abuse women and girls a
court in new york heard statements from
some of his victims who accused him of
being wicked shameless and disgusting
here's joe pike
at the same time he was amassing wealth
fame and power i believe i can fly
our kelly was sexually abusing children
but even after being handed a 30-year
sentence little remorse
does he recognize any extent that his
behavior was wrong
uh as as i said in court mr kelly has
regrets but no he's not guilty of the
charges for which he's been convicted
earlier the singer was forced to sit and
listen as victims described him as
disgusting and despicable one told the
court kelly was a pied piper who lured
children with his money and celebrity
judge anne donnelly said there were few
crimes more serious than serial rape and
abuse over many years but the most
troubling aspect of this case is the
fact that r kelly got away with it for
years he was a predator operating in
plain sight and it seemed to be an open
secret that he was a sexual abuser
for those whose lives he damaged relief
i stand here very proud
of my judicial system
very proud of my fellow survivors
and very pleased with the outcome 30
years did he do this and 30 years is
what he got why did it take the police
so long why does it take the police so
long you frustrate it took so long for
you to get justice i can't speak to why
it takes anyone
the amount of time that it takes but
they've done their homework
they've presented their case and now we
have justice in our judicial system r
kelly now faces a further trial for
child pornography offences which he
denies the singer will be in his mid-80s
before he's considered for release joe
pike sky news new york
a new report has recommended that mps
should not be allowed to bring their
babies into the chamber of the house of
commons during debates
the procedures committee were asked to
carry out a review following an outcry
when labour stella creasy was told she
could no longer have her baby son with
her they ruled mps should not bring
babies into the chamber if they want to
observe initiate speak or intervene in
proceedings
now donations have continued to pour
into the bowel babe fund set up by dame
debra james the charity set up to fund
research and awareness of bowel cancer
stands at more than seven million pounds
following the news of her death on
tuesday
now you'll probably recognize uh this
photograph the defining picture of the
vietnam war the image of kim [ __ ] farn t
and she won a politics of actually
the photographer one of the pulitzer
prize when the nine-year-old subject uh
then nicknamed napalm girl she can be
seen as screaming in pain after an
aerial napalm attack left her skin
burning
now 50 years on after suffering decades
of severe pain due to scarring
she has had her final skin treatment she
left vietnam in 1992 moving to canada
where she still lives with her husband
now let me get up and i can show you
these lovely pictures um this morning
looking at this in the guardian there
you go um part of a story warning more
ancient trees need to be protected a
study is suggesting most aren't even on
record it's like something from the
hobbit doesn't it walk
over to mongolia where these hunters are
using eagles to find prey they've been
photographed by a thai photographer as
part of a project
and in the star an orangutan is smiling
at her newborn in a zoo
in germany uh looks like she's having a
lot of fun there doesn't it
uh now still to come as western leaders
meet for the final day of the nato
summit in madrid speaking to the uk's
former permanent representative to the
alliance that's adam thompson coming up
next
[Music]
looking at our top stories for you this
morning on the breakfast show on sky as
putin issues a fresh threat to nato
boyce johnson has pledged to give
ukraine an extra billion pounds in
military support to help kiev in its
fight against russia but the foreign
secretary tells me it's just rhetoric
buckingham palace has refused to release
details of the megan bullying report as
their annual finances show the monarchy
cost the taxpayer more than a hundred
million pounds for the first time last
year
and an investigation has been launched
into the captain tom foundation after
concerns were raised about charities
management and independence from the
late veterans family
telling more about the foreign secretary
saying that the threat from president
putin
excuse me that russia would respond to
any buildup of nato forces in finland or
sweden is rhetoric that we've heard
before
speaking to this programme liz trust
said it's what happens on the ground
that matters and urged members of the
alliance to increase defence spending
we've heard this rhetoric from putin
about all kinds of plans in the past so
he said that it was a red line for him
that finland and sweden would join nato
he said it was a red line if
uh western nations supplied weapons to
ukraine this is rhetoric we have to
ignore the rhetoric and instead do all
we can to continue to support ukraine
with the weapons they need to win this
appalling war because if we don't it
means that there'll be much greater
threat for european security in the
future today we've announced an extra
billion pounds of military aid to
ukraine to help them push russia out of
their territory and we have to focus on
keeping going keeping the support going
to ukraine keeping the sanctions on
russia and really ignoring uh the
rhetoric from vladimir putin what
matters is what happens on the ground
but the rhetoric is now ratcheting up to
cold war levels during the cold war um
our spending in the uk was five percent
of gdp how much more would you like to
see an increase of the spending as a
percentage of gdp here in the uk well
our spending is currently 2.3 percent of
gdp we've put an extra 24 billion pounds
of spending in yesterday or today we
announced the extra billion to support
ukraine what we now need to see is our
allies and partners step up because the
figure you quoted kay is a figure for
nato overall some partners are still not
spending the two percent i see the two
percent as a flaw it's a minimum and we
need to make sure that we're all
contributing and making sure that the uh
defense and deterrence is much more
effective
um ali is here i'm not sure she answered
my question
no well i think she was surprisingly
bullish when it came to defense spending
in a sense actually that's not really a
surprise because just a couple of months
ago she was talking about the nato
target of 2 being a floor not a ceiling
she repeated that to you again today and
i thought this quote was particularly
good she said we need to make sure our
defense budget is fit for purpose and of
course while um she and the prime
minister have been in madrid talking
tough on ukraine and we know they've
talked about a billion more pounds that
they're going to spend to help support
ukraine saying that their second only to
us back at home there has been this
debate over defense spending ben wallace
suggesting to you yesterday that in the
sort of middle to longer term um he
would like to see more defense spending
given that the situation has changed
with what's going on in ukraine and
questions over that 0.5 above inflation
pledge that the government made in 2019
and whether that's actually going to be
kept on a year by year basis so there
has been um this debate going on here
the other interesting part um perhaps
worth mentioning was on finland and
sweden because we had
president putin suggesting that it would
be met in kind if there was any nato
infrastructure in those countries that
are joining nato
and on that she basically said this is
rhetoric we've heard this sort of thing
before so she was talking tough on
ukraine and on putin and surprisingly
bullish perhaps on defence spending okay
we'll see if ali's take at nine o'clock
yes look forward to it thank you
let's speak now should we to sir adam
thompson the former uk permanent
representative to nato hello to you
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us on the program this morning
you've heard i'm sure what uh president
putin has been saying and the response
from our foreign secretary this morning
um
what's your take on that how concerned
should we be about the rhetoric from
president putin
president putin's used rhetoric as a
a weapon of war almost over ukraine he
started with a lot of threatening
nuclear rhetoric
not all of it has come to pass
and liz trust is right that what really
matters is what happens on the ground
but president putin has suffered a whole
succession of of damaging defeats
first of all in ukraine and now with
nato expansion precisely the thing he
claims to be going into ukraine to try
to stop and that arguably makes him more
dangerous so
we do need to
look at russian intentions
even if we don't believe
all their threatening words
and finland and sweden joining nato
there would be
little point i suppose unless they were
also given the appropriate armory and
support from other nato countries so as
a result you know we are going to see um
more challenges from putin aren't we
well one of the really important things
for nato about finland and sweden is
that they actually strengthen the
alliance
rather than
weakening it
it's true
that
the arrival of finland
in nato dramatically increases nato's
order with russia and that border will
now have to be guaranteed by nato's
security guarantee but the finns are
a very capable
military force so
as nato has said in its madrid
declaration
finland and sweden joining actually
makes
the alliance stronger
it
will be a
strategic concern for the russians uh a
weakened russia however as a result of
its military adventure uh in ukraine
it does extend the
range of
possible
points of confrontation between
nato and russia and nato needs to be
thinking about how it does
risk reduction with russia and not just
defense buildup
um talk to me about what's called the
strategic concept for nato i know you
know a lot about this you've been
writing about it recently what needs to
be changed
the
strategic concept is nato's second most
important document after its foundation
treaty uh it's something that the
alliance tends to revise and produce
roughly uh once a decade the last one
was done in 2010 in dramatically
different circumstances this strategic
concept really
embodies a a geopolitical earthquake
driven by russia's invasion
of ukraine uh it takes the nate takes
nato right back to uh its core
uh purpose of collective defense of all
its allies uh and it reflects uh the
decisions at madrid of a
massive increase in specifically
european
military readiness a dramatic change
in nato's force structure so that it can
more quickly
defend and reinforce
along its eastern borders or indeed
anywhere else
um
i wonder if you could talk to me also
about
suggestions of um significant concerns
with cyber warfare for nato
we heard didn't we the head of the army
speaking about cyber as part of his
maiden speech if you will earlier on in
the week but he said cyber doesn't get
you across a river
fair enough but cyber can be
dramatically
destabilizing and disruptive of a
society and of an economy
it's true it's a feature of
the ukraine conflict that although there
has been uh very extensive russian cyber
attacks uh on ukraine the ukrainians
have proved more resilient and russia
doesn't seem to have extended its cyber
activities so far to get at
western nato
countries
but it is undeniably now a domain of
modern warfare
nato has
integrated it as such along with space
in its military thinking
and
it is going to require substantial
investment by allies
nato likes to say that the
alliance is only as strong as its
weakest link and not all allies are very
strong links as far as cyber resilience
is
concerned um final question to you if i
may
been lots of
conversation about us the rhetoric
heading towards
pre-cold war levels at that stage
the
budget for uh nato was five percent of
gdp for its members uh presently it's
two percent do you think that needs to
be looked at again
i think nato first needs to see its
allies all getting to two percent but
it's undeniable that we are in a 21st
century version of uh a cold war small c
school w
uh the uh dynamics are all very familiar
to anyone who lived through the
20th century cold war and i'm afraid
those dynamics are going to drive
rising uh defense spending what we need
to see alongside that cold war dynamic
is some of the 20th century
vision for
how nato
copes with a neighbor like russia
and what the roles are for diplomacy and
dialogue alongside defense and
deterrence
good to talk to you thank you so much
for taking the time to join us on the
program this morning thank you
just hearing that
actually from heath rowe if you're
heading to heathrow this morning you
really do need to check before you set
off to the airport a statement from
heathrow saying we're expecting higher
passenger numbers in today's morning
peak than the airport currently has
capacity to serve and so to keep
everyone safe we've asked airlines to
remove 30 flights from the morning peak
for today only we will work with
airlines to get effective passengers
rebooked onto other flights outside of
the peak so that as many as possible can
get away today and we apologize for the
impact this has had on travel plans so
basically if you are heading to heathrow
this morning you thought you were
getting an early flight you need to
check before you set off 30 flights have
been moved
now while the prime minister has pledged
more money to help support ukraine in
its fight against russia ukrainian
soldiers are already being trained by
british troops right here in the uk our
defense and security editor deborah
haynes has joined them on an exercise
firing practice for ukrainian soldiers
far away from the front line
[Music]
they've come to the uk to hone their
skills on solsby plane
but this is no ordinary war game
these troops are heading back to ukraine
to fight russia for real
the ability to use long-range guns could
prove vital
[Music]
the sense of urgency makes them the most
dedicated of students for their trainers
a mix of soldiers from britain
and also new zealand
yeah we definitely see the high degree
of motivation and dedication to the
defense of ukraine and these guys they
are committed to the training they don't
take many breaks they certainly get
involved
they have no choice as these first
pictures of their training taken last
weekend show
the ukrainian troops are those in the
black vests and helmets they didn't want
to speak on camera these soldiers are
locked in a war with russia yet they've
come here to solsby plane for training
on weapons that they believe will be key
in helping to turn the tide in the
conflict
these old guns with a range of seven
miles were bought by the uk to be gifted
to ukraine
[Music]
but this is the kind of weapon that
could make the big difference
a multiple launch rocket system which
can hit a target more than 50 miles away
ukrainian soldiers are being trained on
these too
their hunger to learn and their need to
take risk meant a more slow and steady
approach to teaching was quickly ditched
it came as a shock to us we we prepared
the training program and the training
content based on our experience uh
delivering training to british soldiers
and when we found out that they were
professional rocket artillerymen
the content of the course
and delivering that became much easier
britain has trained hundreds of
ukrainian troops in the past few weeks
and is about to coach many thousands
more
new support for ukraine is a key theme
for nato allies meeting this week in
madrid under the shadow of russia's war
prime minister boris johnson is using
the summit to announce another one
billion pounds of military aid that
ukraine's president while grateful for
the west's assistance has warned that
the allies must do more to help his
country win
back on solsby plane the ukrainian
soldiers say their new skills will help
them as they return to the fight
after this brief change of scene
debra haynes sky news madrid
a growing shortage of doctors could mean
one in four dps posts could be vacant in
the next 10 years a new report from the
health foundation think tank says the
result could be a significant risk to
the quality of care that patients
received
joined now by the vice chair of the
royal college of gps and that's dr
margaret ikpo hello to thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
doctor how worried are you
extremely worried kay um it's really
concerning but sadly not unsurprising we
set out a fit for vision for fit for
future for general practice three years
ago at the college anticipating um like
the think tank that in eight years time
will be you know have a real chronic
shortage of gps
and when you say chronic shortage what's
what does that look like what does that
mean in real terms
so in real terms what that means is
a quarter of our workforce will simply
just not be there for patients to access
um we know that patients are currently
having
problems accessing general practice
that's not a new thing but what's
happened and covert has exacerbated
issues is that the pressure on um
general practices has intensified um
quite significantly so we're seeing um
people retiring much early and leaving
the profession um our own college
conducted a survey which is in line with
what's happening where 19 000 are
expected to leave within the next five
years so these figures are really really
worrying and of course it's not just
general practitioners it's our practice
nurses as well who are also feeling the
heat and the stresses of everyday
practice and that we're experiencing
okay so how do we solve the problem
so what we've been asking for so our fit
for vision um campaign which was
launched last week is asking for a
number of things we need a new
recruitment and retention strategy
especially if we're going to try and hit
the target or you know we need to move
beyond the target of the 6000 gp
shortage that was announced in 2015. we
need to look at an nhs public facing
campaign so that patients can understand
the different number of roles that exist
within the practice we need to campaign
for gps to free up our time so we can
spend more time with our patients
because we really want to spend time
with our patients and remove the
unnecessary workload and bureaucracy
that currently exists
we need to look at i.t we need digital
enablement the other day you know i was
able to log on within five minutes and
almost fall off fell off my chair
because it was that quick and but that
shouldn't be new that should be just a
standard we need the id for patients to
be able to access and book in in a
timely way so they can see their patient
sorry the gp on the same day or the next
available member
and we need to look at premises we need
some significant investment you know
over a billion in our premises we simply
don't have enough capacity or space to
house our wider teams our trainees or
and to see our patients which is the
most important thing those are the
things that we're asking the government
to do set out a bold new strategy to
really really
make our working lives better to provide
quality patient care
okay doctor we must leave it there but
thank you for taking the time to join us
much appreciated thank you thank you
thank you thanks a lot quick look at the
weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
weather sponsored by qatar airways
next few days looking unsettled
widespread showers some heavy with hail
and thunder fine and mild for most but
there are heavy showers around mainly
over scotland southwestern ireland and
near northern irish sea coasts
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
still to come on the programme for you
as the prime minister pledges additional
military support to nato and ukraine
going to be speaking to labour's shadow
defense secretary john healey we were
actually speaking to the foreign
secretary in the hour just gone you can
catch up with what she had to say on our
twitter feed at k burley use the hashtag
k burley we'll share that with you
towards the end of the show you can also
check us out on youtube as well as guy
news has our dedicated channel on
youtube we will have some clips as well
from the foreign secretary coming up in
just a few moments time also looking
ahead to later on in the programme are
you any good at barbecuing
no me neither but we've got an aussie on
the beach in australia to show you how
best to do it oh yeah that's something
to look forward to isn't it especially
with all this bad weather stay tuned for
more here on skype
[Music]